parler du classement forbes cette
semaine qui est sorti sur les chanteuses
les mieux payés au monde ce que ça vous
choque ou pas c'est assez hallucinant
dans le magazine américain vous doutez
pas beaucoup de français dans le
classement des chanteuses fait mieux
payés et si c'est surprenant il ya
laurie en dedans je plaisante katy perry
qui truste la première place alors
garder un petit peu on les a mis hier
mois katy perry 83 millions de dollars
en un an voilà il ya eu la tournée plus
le dise qu'elle prend 1 million de
dollars par soir donc c'est assez simple
de faire de calculs elle a fait 80 da de
80 millions taylor swift 80 millions
beyoncé 60 millions on a ri à nantes 7e
place à 37 millions britney spears à 30
millions de dollars
voilà est-ce que ça vous choque ou pas
ces montants qu'ils sont c'est-à-dire
presque indécent et en même temps
peut-être que s'il gagne autant c'est
qu'il faut rapporter au paon autant
est-ce que ça vous choque ou pas choquer
oui myriam pourquoi moi je suis assez
choqué de deux de ces montants que je
trouve complètement déconnecté avec la
réalité et je trouve qu'il serait
intéressante peut-être de baisser
certaines places de concert peut être
gagné un peu moins d'argent pour
permettre à plus de gens d'aller en
concert excuse moi mais je lui je t'aime
bien mais ce que tu dis ça c'est au
contraire totalement connecté à la
réalité puisqu'ils sans rapport aux gens
qui viennent les voir au nombre donc
temps qui rapporte de l'argent qui font
vivre des milliers de personnes ils sont
payés en proportion il faut soutenir un
pli une chose c'est qu'il ya dix ans il
ya 15 ans les sommes étaient bien plus
élevés avant parce qu'on vend des
disques aujourd'hui on vend pratiquement
plus de disques avant vous vendiez 10
millions d'un album aujourd'hui vous en
rendez 500 milles donc il faut bien un
moment que les stars seraient prévus sur
les comptes à dire que si tu passais mon
temps à mathieu c'est la crise c'est
avec la crise
quatre premiers héros par ans n'a score
mais on gagne plus d'argent aujourd'hui
sur les concerts que sur les disques
donc forcément le cas les gens qui
travaillent avec eux gagne autant
d'argent
c'est normal mais moi ça me moi ça me
choque je trouve que c'est cesser
totalement indécent mais il ya quand
même un truc qui est bien chez les
américains c'est que ce qu'on appelle
celle et charities vous chers que les
américains en fait contrairement aux
français les américains gagnent beaucoup
d'argent mais eux ils donnent beaucoup
c'est qu'il fauche touchèrent fort
partagé après le succès qu'on a eu donc
il donne beaucoup pour des bonnes
oeuvres
eux ils le font tant qu'ils aimeraient
que les français qui critiquent
ça ne fasse aussi comme ça ça va trois
secondes il peut finir sa femme aux
oscars